do you play every day often and then
with the iphone of course
it's instant recording what's on your
iphone do you have about a billion
different little snippets of songs that
you hear in your head is that how you
right now i have an iphone
full too full of little fragments like
jesus
so i'm looking here's my what do i call
piano guitar harmonium
next one bonfire 5th of november next
one
autumnal next one john's boots
let's hear john's boots what does that
mean john's boots man
[Music]
okay
etc what would you do in john's boots
are we talking about the john or a
different john yeah now we're talking
about the
john v john johnny because of the
technology back in the day
do you think there were songs that you
thought of that might have been
absolutely brilliant that you actually
forgot because
you had to go somewhere and find i guess
a piece of paper or a
something to record your ideas into
you must have lost a million songs that
way no you have to remember
everything the great training i would be
a neurotic mess
no i thought well if i forget it he'll
remember it it turns out he thought well
if he forgets it i'll remember
i think you know we used to say look if
we can't remember it
how's the people gonna remember it so we
have to write memorable songs